hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting game that comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber here you
have it mr. YT MND man suggest you
LaBrie versus Johann Assessor 1917 he
says it's one of the deepest moves ever
so I'm very interested in if it's indeed
one of the deepest moves ever and what
will your thoughts about it be so while
we're waiting to continue with the Bobby
Fischer series I don't have a couple of
books on Fischer which I really enjoy
like my friend Bobby Fischer by Dmitry
billets and also Boris Spassky on the
move which is essential but Boris
Spassky but at one point you know they
they meet so it's basically two books
that join into one but I also ordered a
book specifically about the 1972 match
in reykjavik by sweaters illegal reach
and one by Larry Evans so I will only
continue the series once the book
arrived and once I study them a bit as I
want to make the series as nice as
possible should be somewhere around four
to five days so up until then I'm just
gonna be checking up on some of your
suggestions and you know perhaps follow
up on something that's currently going
on in the world so here we have again
between Gillibrand johannes Esther gulab
rare was one of Hungary Hungarian
strongest chess players he was also a
Budapest champion in 1912 a very strong
player for for for a long time for
example in nineteen it's in 1917 he won
a first place in Berlin I had of really
strong players like F&W of solitaire
taco very sure the Vettii gaza Marazzi
so quite a player and he plays against
Johan accessor who I don't really have a
photo of and don't have any additional
information about him but he is a pretty
pretty strong player as well one of his
most notable games is his great victory
in Budapest over Richard reti none other
than so definitely a strong player and
gulab rare
also has a positive score against Mac
silver so well also says something about
his strength and this is a very
interesting game I hope you enjoy it now
let's check out what's what's this deep
move all
we have brer opens with d4 we have d5 c4
and c6 and might be important to mention
that you litter was one of the one of
the leading pioneers of the hyper modern
school of chess alongside Richard reti
basically you don't the hyper modern
school of chess was about not
controlling the center with the pawns at
least not in the beginning of the game
rather with the pieces so such as the
ready opening Knight to f3 where you
wanna finger your bishops and so on and
so on but as you see in this game brayer
also used the c4 and d4 and also e4 in
some games so okay we have c6 the Slav
defense III Knight to f6 knife the c3
and a six
Richard variety also commented on this
game which I'll put a link in
description below so you can check out
some of his comments as well he says
that this is d3 move although somewhat
team is something very usual he wanted
to do he wanted to keep his pieces
behind his pawns so he can unleash them
later so okay Bishop to d3 we have
Bishop to d6 and now f4 it's very
interesting here the engine gives knife
to f3 as the strongest move and retty
specifically says that f4 is a much
stronger move because it doesn't block
the f2 pawn with the deny so first you
play f4 and only then you play Knight to
f3 which is very interesting because the
engine prefers Knight to f3 to f4 like a
lot but you know I wouldn't dismiss what
errata says so lightly because like
we've mentioned is a hyper modern player
he's all about strategic openings making
long-term plans not about any tactical
shots or anything like that and we've
seen in the alpha 0 games that engines
are not all-knowing it's ok f4
we have castles Knight to f3 now that's
the d4 and e4 pawn have been played the
d5 square it will be an excellent
outpost for the night D captures on c4
and now white doesn't automatically
recapture but rather Bishop to be
why waste a move to recapture a pawn
it's basically just a double the pawn
here and you can have a nice Bishop on
v1
I'm the black king and pretty much all
of your pieces are eyeing the black king
the Queen will at some point most likely
come to h5 then I didn't come to joopa
g5 an excellent attacking position for
white black pushes b5 preparing b4 and
it will not be all that easy to develop
this light square bishop this is also
something ready mentions if white
captured this c4 pawn then Bishop three
six would be a nice developing move for
the bishop now that blacks own pawn is
blocking it with with it being on c4 and
there's a really no pointing in playing
Bishop to e6 if there are any newer
subscribers to this channel as usual I
am wearing a hoodie to honor the hoodie
guy as we don't have a photo of him
efore and now Bishop to e7 yeah you
don't want to play b4 although it is
possible you don't want to run into e5
for example captures captures and now
what does have this very strong central
pawn chain but he will have to break it
at some point but I can simply continue
playing there should be seven castles
and it's it's a fine position for black
but black first goes Bishop to e7
we have Knight to g5 h6 and now we have
a position that you will often meet in
your own blitz games for example you
have this beautiful light square bishop
eyeing the black king you have the dark
square Bishop also eyeing the h6 pawn of
course through the pawn and the night
you can perhaps unleash this rook from
h1 the Queen can also perhaps join the
attack so here there's really no point
in moving back the night white continues
the attack simply with h4 offering a
knight here and more often than not when
someone offers you his his knight this
way by playing h4 it's most likely not a
good idea to capture it for example if
you could capture it here and attack the
f6 Knight you can't move the knight you
have to give the material back if you
move it the damn Queen to h5 followed by
Queen to h7 or h8 will be checkmate if
f6 is pushed
then you can push even g6 but ok if if
you try and stop the attack let's see g6
simply G captures on f6 butter captures
c5 now Bishop moves and now Queen to f3
the threat of course is still Queen h3
followed by Queen to h7 checkmate and
here it's simply a much better position
for white there's no no one would like
playing this full black of course you
cannot capture and undie for I are
simply gonna get this Queen to h3 move
after some developing moves and now if
you move the rook then Bishop to c5 will
guard the f8 square again Queen to f8
seven will be a threat and if f5 then
Knight to e4 is is a destroyer
for example pawn captures Queen h7 King
moves now Bishop captures here
the threat is capturing on g6 now
whatever you do you're still gonna
you're still gonna get checkmate it or
or lose a whole other material so this
is only one of the things that can
happen if you capture on g5 so g6 first
not allowing this Queen to come to h5 in
the future we have a five here and only
now H captures on g5 and okay you don't
want to capture back on f6 you want to
open line so H captors on g5 we have
Knight to d5 offering a trade on d5 and
this is the critical moment of the game
where the magic happens
and this is why the title of the video
is what it is and why mr. white emn D
man says that it's one of the deepest
moves ever so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find that deepest
move ever it's not an easy move to find
it's hard to say if it's even the
greatest move it's such a deep position
that anything could be possible here but
yeah just feel free to pause the video
here and think about the position for a
bit what would you play here
I'll give it a couple of seconds first
to the side as usual so for those of you
who pause the video and thought about
the position congratulations you are an
excellent
thinker as the weekend is coming and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
in this position you'll abrir play King
to f1 now King to f1 seems like a very
impressive move I mean of course there
must be something behind it we named the
video after it after all the reason he
played King to f1 is next now for
example a lot of you who have paused the
video and thought about the position
probably consider something like Queen
to f3 or g4 followed by h3 and
checkmating the black king so let's see
what happens if Queen to g4 then King to
g7 is coming and now you don't really
have the option of playing something
like Queen to h3 because rook to h8 will
stop your attack so you would have to
sacrifice a look here after King
captures let's say Queen h5 check the G
pawn is pinned from the bishop you
cannot capture the Queen and now after
Queen King g8 Bishop captures captures
captures King moves Queen h6 check and
after King moves comes this of course
black can always draw this game white
can always draw this game by repeating
the moves here but of course you want to
win the game g6 and now of course the
threat is Queen to h7 checkmate the
problem is black can actually win this
game now because he has a Bishop to h4
check you have to react to this European
is in check you move the king and now
comes Queen to e7
and now you've defended h7 White has no
ways of continuing this attack you are
down so much material and you are just
going to lose this game as white so
after this Knight to d5 move white so
all of this and he decided ok so simply
king to f1 there will now be Bishop to
h4 check in the future because my king
is now on f1 so now my idea must work
right well let's see if this is in fact
so black played Knight captures on c3 ok
eliminating one of the pieces be
captures on c3 and now Bishop to b7 a
very interesting move although there
isn't really a good move here if he
tried you know a preemptive preemptive
strike against white hawai twin g4 idea
with King to g7 it doesn't work because
white will immediately
sacrifice a rock with rock 2h7 without
even touching the Queen King captures
only now comes Queen Queen to h5 check
King g8 Bishop captures captures
captures with check King to h8 Queen to
h6 King moves g6 as we've already
mentioned and now of course there is no
Bishop to h4 check so you have to play
rook to f7 to stop checkmate captures
captures Queen to h5 check came to g7
and now f5 this is all something your
brer had to see if he played King to f1
so this is very really amazing because
this is a completely completely winning
position for white for example he
captures on f5 and now Bishop to h6
check King to h7 and now Queen to f7
check doesn't doesn't quite work because
King captures and now I have to remove
the King
you can always block with Bishop to h4
you will not be able to deliver this
rook to h1 so instead after instead of
Queen to f7 you can go east 6e 6 is a
killer move because now you open up the
e-file and now the rook can enter the
attack via the e-file and you have to
capture it if you don't capture it for
example if you try something like Bishop
to f6 you're just gonna get Bishop to f8
check King moves now comes Queen f7
because the point is now on e6 so Queen
f7 is possible King moves and now King
to e2 and now there is no defense
against rook rook to h1 even if you do
something like this doesn't really
matter rook h1 check and after you block
then comes Queen to g7 because the
bishop is no longer regarding the g7
square so this would be this would in
fact be checkmate so after each six you
would definitely have to capture on e6
Bishop captures but now comes Luke to e1
with a threat against the light square
bishop and the rook of course wants to
enter the game so what can you do here
if you move the bishop let's say Bishop
to g8 Bishop to f8 is a checkmate in one
move of course as the King has nowhere
to go
on the other hand if you try something
different let's say you try and move the
bishop refer back to c8 then you get
Bishop to f8 check King moves and now
Bishop captures here and now it's all
over you have to move the Queen
and then of course queen g6 is coming
and the black is getting checkmated so a
very interesting position and we're
still only at move 15 so King to g7
doesn't work because the rook is
immediately coming to h7 with a nice
rook sacrifice so black tried Bishop to
b7 he thought I can't move the King I'll
just move my Bishop seems like a
reasonable plan white played Queen to g4
of course now pretty much forcing black
to play King to g7 and there's no other
defense you have to play King to g7 here
so now black has to play it but now the
to make matters worse black the black
Bishop is on b7 not on c7 helping out
with the defense here so we have the
same variation King g7 rook h7 you have
to sacrifice the rook King captures
Queen to h5 check King knows now comes
captures captures captures with check
King moves Queen to h6 check King to g8
now comes g6 of course there is no
Bishop to h4 check since we played this
beautiful King to f1 move Roop to f7 you
have to give up some material to prevent
checkmate G captures on f7 King captures
and now Queen to h5 check pink the g7
and now of course f5 pawn captures
Bishop to h6 check came to h7 and now
the Bishop left the c8 square so it's no
longer than necessary to play e6 here we
have although e 6 is still possible and
it does in fact lead to checkmate but
Bishop to g5 was played in the game
which is sufficient King to g8 we have
Queen to g6 check King to h8 and here
Brewer misses a very nice opportunity to
bring the game to an end with Bishop to
f6 check because if Bishop captures pawn
captures if you're threatening checkmate
here after Queen to g8 you have Queen to
h5 check Queen to h7 you have Queen
check here again black has the block and
now of course all of you see the move
I'm just gonna give you a second to see
the move because this can happen to you
very often in your own games simply have
seven and now it's all over you're
threatening checkmate and of course if
captures captures then you bring another
Queen into the game and although black
has some material here it's pretty much
meaningless white can always simply move
his king and bring the rook into the
game and to win the game that way so
after King to h8 Queen to h6 was played
with check sorry about that
I came to g8 and now Queen to e6 check I
move a move order that really wasn't
necessary King to f8 was played and now
Queen captures on f5 with check King to
g7 and now comes the Bishop to h6 with
check so now you've seen what could have
happened and this game could have
already been over but now whitey decides
the further give up some material and he
try he will try to checkmate the black
King we have King captures and King to
e2
now of course the rook to h1 is a
terrible threat Bishop to c8 was played
you have to move the King immediately
from the from the H file and the not
allow rook to h1 to come with checks so
Bishop will be able to block it but
instead Bishop to c8 was played and okay
still playable rock to h1 check Bishop
to h4 and now II 6 a very nice move by
White Queen to e7 and now comes Queen to
f4 going after the bishop on h4 we have
King the g7 rook captures on h4 and now
Queen captures on h6 any sex with check
King to d2 and here you have to bust
open the Queen side immediately go after
the White King because I mean although
you are up material all of your pieces
are undeveloped you have to do something
about this
but here white played black plays Knight
to a6 and this was not not the greatest
move we have looked to h5 the threat of
course being rook to g5 check followed
by Queen to h4 and here black makes a
terrible mistake although there there
isn't really a move that's that's good
like Bishop to d7 it is playable but
black black doesn't find it and he
actually plays Queen to f6 so feel free
to pause the video here if you are
perhaps on a vice chess player and find
the winning idea here for why
I'll give you a couple of seconds to the
side for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations
you are an excellent Rock mover and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
rook to h7 with check of course wins the
game if you captured then you're gonna
lose the Queen but there's no better
move even if you play something like
this then it's even worse you're getting
rook to h6 check and now you're gonna
lose the Queen for nothing and also
you're getting checkmated so King
captures on h7 was played we have Queen
captures on f6 and now you have a
problem the knight has no squares
this is taking this is taken if you go
to c7 then Queen checks and picks up the
night if you move the Bishop to d7 also
check and you lose the bishop if you
move it anywhere else you can't move it
here you can't move it here due to the
Queen this is guarded by the pawn
there's no move black can play here even
though he does have material some
material to compensate for the Queen
how about it's pointless Bishop to g4
was played but now comes Queen to h4
check King g7 and Queen captures on g4
with check King f6 Queen to f3 check
King to e7 Queen to c6 check sword
without to check between to c6 attacking
add the knight and the rook we have rook
moves to g8 and now Queen captures on a
6-row captures and g2 and now King to c1
and here it was in this position that
Johannes SR resigned to the game so a
really wild game and it could have gone
either way white really messed up at
that one point where he didn't want to
play Bishop to f6 the move we mentioned
here he continued Queen to h6 instead of
winning the game immediately brush up to
f6 but you know yeah you have to keep
the drama going that's what makes a
chess game great but it's a very
important that also rich already
mentions that on move 14 let me just
check move 14 where Knight captures and
c3 was played if instead of this black
immediately makes a room for the Queen
to join a 7 by playing Bishop to b4 then
the idea is next captures on d5 captures
on d5 and now Bishop to e3
after king to g7 now but a rope to h7
check is just as good captures queen h5
check King moves check here King moves
captures captures captures would check
King moves and now comes King to e2
because now the G the G pawn is still
here the bishop is misplaced and the now
rope to each one will be deadly so am a
very nice game and you know now I I do
hope you enjoyed it I'm gonna check up
on some of your other suggestions as
well but yeah this position here sorry
it's it's very interesting that such a
move happens already on move 14 so it's
move 14 here and the white decides King
to f1 what a move and you know what a
move to start the weekend indeed so
there you have it I do hope you enjoyed
it
I would like to thank Davi debe querer
mohammad reza host and shia for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos sure
thank you all for watching and I will
see soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and I'm very
interested in your opinion to share in
the comments was the suggestor of this
video correct is this one of the deepest
moves ever thank you all and I'll see
you soon